[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROB SADOWSKI: My
name is Rob Sadowski.
I work in the product
organization on security
and trust here at Google Cloud.
We'll also have Eugene Liderman.
He's going to speak
later about devices,
and I'll let him do his own
introduction in publicity.
So what are we going
to cover today?
Here's our agenda.
To do this topic
justice, I think
first we need to describe what
we mean by modern end user
computing.
What's modern?
Who are the users?
This baseline
understanding is really
going to help us
understand and think
through what it takes to
provide robust enterprise
security in that environment.
We're going to need to
think about applications.
We're going to need
to think about users.
We're going to need to
think about devices.
And securing each of these
presents an unique set
of challenges.
But solving the overall
challenge of modern end user
computing and how we
make sure that that's
secure and productive
is going to require
us to follow some basic,
good security principles.
We're going to take a
defense in-depth approach.
We're going to have a solution
that encompasses protection
at multiple layers,
in every layer,
in a much more holistic way.
So let's get in and
start with some context
about the modern end user
computing environment
because it's the thing
that's creating the security
challenges and the opportunities
that we're all facing today.
So everyone hold up your phones.
I know you were told
to silence your phones.
Yes, everyone has a phone.
And how many of you are
taking notes or doing
something else on a laptop?
Some people.
So this is today's reality.
This is what we're talking
about in terms of modern user
computing.
We work wherever we are, even
if we're in a movie theater,
at a conference
in San Francisco.
How is this possible?
Well, one, the access
devices support it.
We have always on connectivity.
We have really, much more
convenient form factors
than lugging around a desktop
or something like that.
We have a decreasing
dependence on fat client apps
that have to work across
multiple operating systems
and things like that.
And that means that you, and
your employees, and the people
that you work with--
the users on these devices can
access your work apps, not just
the consumer-side apps that
you're consumerizing and using
potentially for work stuff.
But you can actually
access the primary tools
in apps you use to
get your job done
through a browser or a much
more lightweight mobile client.
Second, what we are
accessing is increasingly not
sitting in one of
our own data centers.
And that traditionally has
created a lot of challenges
around connectivity and
doing that at scale.
So much more of what
we are accessing
to get our primary work
done is in the cloud.
And therefore, it's
on a public network.
And these networks are
something to which we
have pretty ubiquitous access.
You came to this
conference and just assumed
that you'd have a pretty solid
high bandwidth connection.
Now, that's mostly worked.
If you were here last year--
didn't work so well.
But this year, so
far so good, right?
So we all assume that we were
going to be able to do that,
and that's great.
But failing that-- guess what?
We have a backup.
We have wireless
connectivity on our phones.
So we are always connected.
And that creates a
lot of opportunities,
but potentially,
some challenges.
But why else have we embraced
mobility so strongly?
Because what we find
is that when we do,
it leads to increased
productivity,
increased collaboration,
and reduced overhead.
So some of the data
here is actually really,
really compelling.
There's been a two-year
Stanford study-- two years,
so it's not just, hey,
do a quick survey--
that showed a 13%
increase in productivity
when users work from home.
Again, that's that
modern end user model.
Other research indicates
that employee mobility
leads to 30% better
business processes,
better following of processes,
better redesigning things
to work better, and
23% more productivity.
These are real
significant gains.
And that we find--
and I think this
is our own experience--
that working from home
reduces attrition.
So retaining and
keeping talent is
so important in today's world.
Anything we can do and
something with a lever
like that-- so important.
The other thing is that these
devices and this way of working
allows us to communicate
and work asynchronously.
So asynchronous
communications that
are facilitated by devices
and cloud technology
allow us to be more efficient.
Web-based meetings are
better planned and more
apt to stay on message.
I can't remember the last time I
didn't have a web-based meeting
or do things on
conference calls.
But more and more
and more, we're
getting more done in less time.
The net net is that modern
communication and collaboration
can increase productivity,
again, 25%, 30%, plus,
and increase employee
satisfaction.
And yes, usually when
we talk about benefits,
we go right to costs.
And certainly, there's an
element of cost savings here--
something like that.
You look at what
IBM does-- they've
been really public about
how they have moved
to, essentially, a
remote workforce--
folks that work and are
enabled by these technologies.
And they've saved
more than $50 million
by making many of
their positions remote.
So while cost savings probably
isn't the primary benefit
in a lot of cases, it is
certainly part of the equation.
But this new model of
working means we are also
faced with a new set of risks.
Security professionals--
when you say, OK,
what's going on now?
What are you concerned about?
They find a lot of challenges
in defending against threats
to mobile devices.
And this survey ranks them the
number one hardest enterprise
asset to defend.
There's a lot of
user intervention.
user control there.
That's a pretty
strong statement--
the number one or most
difficult asset to defend.
And 3/4 of organizations
report that they've
suffered some sort
of breach or incident
as a result of a
mobile security issue.
So these aren't likely to be
the big mega breaches where
you aren't storing
hundreds of millions
of records on a mobile device.
But nevertheless, when we
have regulations like GDPR,
where we have to disclose
when personal information is
disclosed-- that type
of information does
get onto devices.
And so this is an
increasing concern,
even if it isn't the large,
mega catastrophic breach
that it may be.
It's all still very,
very important.
So how do we enable
the business?
How do we unleash
that productivity
without increasing or creating
unnecessary security risk?
Well, to do that,
we need a strategy
that thinks through and
understands the whole stack
that we are using to deliver
IT services in this new world.
And as I said before, we
have to take a defense
in-depth approach.
It's not just about the
device, although that's
really important.
It starts at the infrastructure.
We have to think
about the apps that
are on these
devices and the apps
that we are
delivering information
through to these workers.
We have to think about
the users and how
we establish their identity.
We have to think, again,
about the devices.
So we need to build
protection into every layer
and take advantage of the
controls that are there so we
can build end-to-end security.
So what I'd like to do now is
walk through what we can do
in each layer and
what specifically,
you can get from Google Cloud--
what we're doing in many
of these--
in each.
So perhaps now, but
certainly going forward,
the services that workers
access to do their jobs
will be largely
based in the cloud.
And while this used to be
seen as a source of risk,
it's now seen-- cloud
infrastructure is now
seen as a security
enabler or a strength.
Gartner says that over
the next several years,
workloads that leverage
cloud infrastructure--
whatever those workloads are--
will suffer 60% fewer incidents
than those in traditional data
centers.
That is a really, really
strong compelling statement.
And I think that the experience
that people have in operating
the cloud bears this out.
Another study that I cited
in another talk this week
is that going from last year to
this year of organizations that
are putting applications
in the cloud, 90%
plus of them trust
the cloud more.
It's that repeated
positive experience
that they are getting,
that they are realizing
that the cloud, actually--
cloud infrastructure--
is not part of a
security problem.
It's part of the solution.
So how do we leverage
that in this modern world
to increase security?
So the foundational
layer of our stack--
that's what I want you to take
away-- the infrastructure is
getting more secure over time.
In a Google Cloud, the
infrastructure layer
that we provide offers
many unique benefits
that you can take advantage of.
So we do a lot of security by
default. When data is stored--
our services that run in
our cloud when you put data
in there--
all of that data is
encrypted at rest by default,
without any interaction
required by you
on behalf of the customer
or you as a customer.
The second thing that
we do or second thing
I want to highlight is that
the worst thing that can happen
is that someone is working
remotely or working
in the field, and they can't
get to the application.
The size and scope
of our network,
as well as the protections
we've built in by default,
help organizations mitigate
potential network and DDoS
attacks really, really well.
The other thing
is that as you're
deploying apps for those
users to work on, again,
downtime really impacts them.
We do all the infrastructure
patching automatically.
So not only do you
get the benefits
of a constantly updated
infrastructure that's
not subject to
vulnerabilities, but we
don't have to take downtime.
And this was a
particularly great feature
when the processor
vulnerabilities
or a Spectre and Meltdown that
Google researchers actually
found needed to be fixed.
So across our whole
fleet, we were
absolutely able to patch
that in Google Cloud
without taking any
downtime, which
is not the case on
many other services.
The second thing is
that we are building on
or you are building on a
purpose-built infrastructure.
So we design all the
way from the chip
up to the chiller in the data
center, our own infrastructure.
That's the chips that go
in the servers, the servers
themselves, the storage, the
networking gear-- all of that.
We have a private
global network.
And so when we are
accessing services on that,
traffic that gets off
the public internet
and gets on that
network is much less
likely to be intercepted
or manipulated.
And again, I talked a little
bit about the chip side
of things-- we have
hardware-based tamper
protection to make sure that the
infrastructure that your apps,
services, and data sits on is
always in a state that we know.
That we know exactly what is
running there at all times.
And then-- we'll get into
this a little bit later on--
there's a lot of proprietary
controls and expertise
that are embedded here that
you can take advantage of.
So we'll talk a little
bit about the way
that this is G Suite,
like Gmail, do things
like phishing and protection
against malicious email.
We talk about the easy
way you can implement
strong authentication with
security keys and some
of the things we do there.
We talk about the ways we
can prevent data exfiltration
from certain
services, with things,
like, VPC Service Controls.
And just this week,
we introduced a set
of what we call user protection
services that help deal
with risk of suspicious
or malicious URLs
and applications that
look at, again, other ways
to do phishing defense
and protect applications
against abuse by bots
or other like that.
And the other thing that we
do from a security perspective
that is really important as
the operator or administrator
of the infrastructure
like this is we
provide a tremendous amount of
visibility and transparency.
So you maybe heard Urs
in the keynote today talk
about access
transparency, where you
can understand if any cloud
administrators are ever
accessing your data
in the course of doing
support and things like that.
So you can feel confident that
what you are doing is robust.
We also give a lot of visibility
into just overall operations
with our Cloud Security
Command Center on GCP
and our Security
Center within G Suite
to really highlight where
are the particular areas
of security risk.
So what I want to,
again, to take away
is that there's a
really robust foundation
for building the
apps and delivering
the services that these modern
end users, the mobile users,
need.
The other thing is that building
on an infrastructure like this,
you get the assurance that
not only the infrastructure
but the services that sit on
top are validated against some
of the most rigorous global
security and privacy standards
like the SO 27000 series.
And we know that as you adopt
this infrastructure foundation,
you may want to bring some of
your existing security tools
with you.
So we have an extensive
ecosystem of security partners
that deliver their capabilities
on our cloud platform that
runs the gamut, from things like
identity and access management
solutions, monitoring solutions,
GRC solutions, Endpoint
Security--
which I'll talk about
in a few slides here.
Cloud Access Security brokers,
which are really important
for some organizations in
getting the level of control
that they want in this
[INAUDIBLE] world.
So you can preserve
existing investment things
like your endpoint
protection platforms
and still leverage
those as you build
on our cloud infrastructure.
So hopefully, you
take away why cloud--
that foundation
in many ways does
or will underpin what we're
doing around modern end user
computing.
So now, let's turn
our attention to some
of the layers of the stack
we more commonly associate
with these challenges about
the apps, about the users,
and about the devices.
So the layer above
the infrastructure
is the application
layer, and these
can be applications that you
build or deploy in the cloud
yourself.
Or they can be SaaS
apps or other services
from a third-party.
But regardless, we need to think
about, what are the features
and what our capabilities
that we're looking for?
So in terms of what we offer
and the way we think about some
of this within
Google Cloud, G Suite
offers many security
benefits that
are really attuned to the
needs of this modern workforce.
They're much more collaborative
and things like that.
First, G Suite is very--
we have these core
guiding principles
around being proactive, about
being intelligent, making
things simple, and
building compliance.
So in terms of being
proactive, what
we are looking to
do is automatically
block many of the threats
that target cloud workers,
especially in email.
I think we're all aware
that email is the number one
app, the most critical
app for these mobile, more
modern workers.
And G Suite has 99.9% plus
accuracy in blocking spam,
in blocking malicious email,
in dealing with business email
compromise type scams.
All of the outbound email
is checked automatically,
if you turn on things like
DLP for sensitive information,
and so that can be
automatically flagged-- again,
potentially eliminating sources
of risk or data exposure.
And there are built-in
defenses as email
comes in against attachments
carrying ransomware
and other malware that
can get on the device
that users are using and affect
effective security there.
And today, we announced
some new advances
in G Suite in this
area, around stronger
phishing and malware protection.
And some sandboxes
technology that
goes even further in
allowing us to deal with more
sophisticated malware.
So we constantly keep
pushing and trying to advance
the state of the art.
The other thing
that we think about
is, again, this
notion of intelligence
and being proactive.
We want to help stop
threats to this workforce,
to these devices, before they
turn into damaging incidents.
And the intelligence
that's in G Suite
can help surface the
most worrisome security
concerns, like, potential
device compromises.
Part of our G Suite
Security Center
has a whole specific
section that
allows you to look at
your device footprint
and understand-- is there a
potential compromise there?
Which users is it affecting
so you can deal with this?
And we try to do this
without sending you
constant notifications
about less important issues
that are less impactful.
And again, we strive
to make these simple.
We have this philosophy
that security tools
are only useful if
you actually use them,
if you actually deploy them.
And so if they're too
difficult or too complicated,
they're of limited use.
We're always trying
to give admins
simpler, more streamlined
ways to deploy this.
Make a lot of the things
available, again, by default--
like I talked about--
and make them work
out of the box
with the right configurations
right at your fingertips.
Now, when I mention an
application security
layer, how many people actually
thought about browsers?
Maybe some of you, but
perhaps, not many of you.
The fact is many, if not the
majority of corporate apps,
are or will be delivered
in browsers, even
up to productivity things.
Like, think of what
we do with G Suite.
Think of the sophistication.
We get in Docs, and
Sheets, and other things
like that or some of the
other productivity suites.
It's an essential--
the browser really
is an essential part of
that application layer
that we need to have
confidence in the security of.
And Chrome Browser
for Enterprise
designs in many
security features.
We think of that in
three broad areas.
We try to make it safe as
much as possible by design,
so we build those
protections in.
Here, again-- just like we're
describing a multilayered
approach--
Chrome takes that
same multilayered
approach in the browser itself.
And we try to do
many, many things
to keep ahead of the threat
landscape that targets the end
user environment.
So in terms of being
safe by design,
we employ technologies
like Safe Browsing, which
protects from a range
of malware, phishing,
and social engineering
attacks-- the sites that
might be able to steal
passwords or infect machines
that would affect those users.
This is a constantly
updated database
as we crawl the web
of what we perceive
or what we see as
potentially malicious sites.
And we'll provide
warnings to users
before they navigate to those.
So again, it gets that
distributed notion
of warning or control out to
users wherever they may be.
Chrome automatically
updates-- this
is so important for this
modern mobile workforce.
If you're not in the office,
if you're not doing updates--
if IT staff and team and desktop
support staff is not touching
that on a regular basis
where they can do updates--
we have to constantly update the
OS, the application software,
and all those other pieces.
Because we know
that vulnerabilities
get exploited very rapidly.
The fact that cloud-based
services automatically update
and Chrome browser especially
automatically updates
is really, particularly
important to make sure
that the users have the latest
security features and fixes
without requiring
any intervention.
Sandboxing is another
thing in terms of design
that is very, very useful in
terms of the Chrome Security
model.
It helps prevent malware from
installing itself on devices,
reduces the severity and impact
of certain vulnerabilities
that might be exploited.
It also works, again,
to prevent eavesdropping
or other intercept
of communications
as the browser
accesses websites.
So it uses network
security features
like strict transport security,
things like public key pinning,
things like verification
of route CAs to make sure.
So building on what we do
at Google around certificate
transparency in doing things
like mixed script locking.
So there's a lot of things
or a lot of potential ways
that a browser can be exploited,
but the design of Chrome
tries to neutralize or make
many of those, much less--
or make itself much
less susceptible
to those type of techniques.
And Chrome really works
to stay ahead of threats.
There's a public
commitment to releasing
a fix for any critical security
vulnerability in under 60 days,
and on average those
vulnerabilities
are fixed within 30 days.
Even when necessary-- we think
something is particularly
severe--
we've pushed fixes
in under 24 hours.
So the team is really
always actively
working to find and
fix vulnerabilities
before they affect
users, and that's
that point about trying
to stay and working
to stay one step ahead
of potential adversaries.
So that's the app layer.
But what about users?
How should we think
about protecting
this broad and increasingly
growing user community?
I think that's the first
point I want to make.
The notion of who is a user
in this more modern world
is evolving.
It's not just employees.
It goes beyond that.
It's vendors.
It's partners.
It's contractors.
It's customers.
And all of those different
user constituencies
require different
levels of access
to different information,
to different data sources,
to different applications,
from different places,
on different devices.
Think of that matrix.
It's complicated.
How can we help deal with
some of those challenges?
So back in 2011, Google
came up with a new approach
for access management dealing
with these types of challenges.
We called it BeyondCorp, and
this enterprise security model
started off as an
internal Google initiative
to say that, hey, we want to
enable any of our employees
to work anywhere,
essentially, in the world
from untrusted networks.
We want to rely on
the internet, not
have to rely on a VPN,
which can be very complex.
This actually sounds really
close to this description
of modern end-user computing
that I talked about
at the beginning.
So what BeyondCorp aims to do
is shift the access controls
being solely based
at the network layer
and around the perimeter,
to switch that much, much
more into--
make it much, much
more about context--
about the user,
about the device,
and what they're accessing, and
arbit decisions based on that.
Don't just make an assumption
about trusting the network,
because we know that these
modern end-users are not
going to be working from
inside the office where we
have that presumption of trust.
And because of the trends that
we've been speaking about,
there's been tremendous
support for an idea like this.
If any of you were
at the RSA security
conference over the past month,
I think the biggest theme that
came out for me was
this idea around,
how do we implement
zero trust networking?
How do we take models
like BeyondCorp
and actually make them real?
Because, conceptually, they
address a lot of the challenges
that we've been talking about.
Here's a great quote
from Steve Pugh.
He's at a company called Ionic
now, who's a Google partner,
but he used to be in
the office of the CTO
and various branches
of the military
and in the White House.
And he says this
vision is really
the future of enterprise IT.
This is the modern world
that we are dealing with.
It's a model that
builds on zero trust
and combined with best-of-breed
ideas from the community.
So we've tried to
adapt and see what
are the challenges in
terms of implementation
and adjust and go on.
And so, at Google
Cloud, we've been
working really hard
over the past year or so
to help you implement a
similar type model-- implement
this BeyondCorp model
for your users--
through a set of products and
capabilities on our platform
and in our services.
We put this under
the umbrella of what
we call context-aware access.
We want to enable you to
make context-aware access
decisions for any type of
user to any type of resource
within Cloud.
What we do here is, we take
inputs from the user side,
and we take input
from the device side,
and then we incorporate a whole
range of contextual factors--
like IP address, like
location, like the time of day,
like the length of the session.
We run those through
a rules engine
that we call Access
Context Manager,
and we leverage a number
of enforcement points
so that we can control
access for remote users
to the diverse set of
resources that they're
looking to get access to.
So whether those are
web apps, whether those
are virtual machines, whether
those are other services
or resources on GCP,
whether those are APIs,
whether that's G Suite, whether
that's generic SaaS apps,
any of those we want to be able
to set precise access policies
and rules that take into
account the environment
that users are
finding themselves in.
And a key enabler for this
that Google Cloud is providing
is our Cloud Identity solution.
So it's our repository
for user information
that we have to understand.
It's our identity as a service
solution or IDaaS solution
that offers [AUDIO OUT]
one single place to manage
users, apps, and devices.
It allows you to get this
context-aware access capability
for G Suite and SaaS apps.
It allows you to help
with the account hijacking
side of things, to
implement strong two-factor
authentication with security
keys and other methods
to prevent account takeovers.
It does a lot of account
protection in the background
based on Google's
intelligence and signals
and what we do to protect
the billions of accounts
that access our services.
It offers-- this is really
important-- integrated
unified endpoint
management, both
from a lightweight perspective
and also more in-depth,
if you want to do that.
So to get that touch,
it offers a dashboard
that I made a little
bit of mention
of in terms of highlighting
where are the biggest
sources of risk
and what's going on
across these
different identities.
And this is a service that is
now today used by customers
to manage more than 100
million users and over 55
million devices.
So this is one of the best-kept
secrets inside Google Cloud
and really is a
fundamental underpinning
of how we are enabling and how
we are helping people to work
in this new modern environment.
So what I wanted to do is kind
of stop talking and do a little
bit of a demo to show you
how this actually might work,
to show you how these
different layers--
from the infrastructure layer
to the app layer to the user
protection layer--
how all these can
work in concert
and how implementing
context to our access
for your modern end-users
actually looks like.
Here's a business scenario that
poses a lot of the challenges
that we face dealing with
this modern end-user computing
environment.
We have a company called Zotkix.
They work with a
company called Acme.
So already we see the complexity
and the collaborative nature
of work.
In this scenario, the
Zotkix HR department
is going to hire or bring on
some contractors from Acme
to help with a few
things, so they
are going to need access
to the internal HR system.
Well, there is no notion
of an internal system.
We want to make that
available as a service,
so that users can
access it theoretically
from wherever they are.
But the security policies
that they have in place
require some very specific
things for contractors
to access them.
They should use strong
authentication in every case.
And in this particular
case for HR,
we actually aren't
going to allow
you to work from anywhere.
You must be accessing this
from a company office.
And so the IT
department-- while this
may have been a daunting
challenge in the past,
it's absolutely
the type of thing
we have to do in today's
world, in today's environment.
So their IT department
says consider it
done to both HR and security.
So how are they
going to do that?
Well, they're going to
deploy this HR application
on Google Cloud.
They're going to define VPC-- a
Virtual Private Cloud network--
for the wrap, and they're
going to stand it up
on Google Compute Engine.
And then they're going to set
up Cloud Load Balancing right
at the edge for ingress
from the internet,
and they're going to use
the Cloud Identity Aware
Proxy, which is integrated
right into Cloud Load Balancing,
to front-end the app.
Those are all the
features that they have.
They're taking advantage
of what's there.
And the Identity
Aware Proxy IP is
going to draw on
user information
that they maintain
in Cloud Identity.
It's going to rely
on device status
from endpoint verification
and Chrome browser,
and the Access
Context Manager is
going to be used to define
their access policy.
So this is why I talked about
the Cloud infrastructure layer
first in talking about
modern end-user computing.
These key enabling
services that we
need to enable us to
work the way we want
are part of the infrastructure
where the app and the data
and the mobile users
that they're going
to access where all this lives.
So let's take a look at
what this looks like.
The first thing
I'm going to do is
I'm going to set up the access
policy that restricts access
to the office for this
app for contractors.
And because I fear the
demagogues a little bit
in a movie theater and
I respect your time,
I actually recorded
this earlier.
So what I'm going to do
is go to the GCP console,
and I'm going to go to Security
and go to Access Context
Manager--
so really easy to do
right here in the console.
And you can see
as we select this,
I have a whole set of
existing policies here,
but I want to go and
define a new access level,
and I'm going to call
this From Acme Office.
Make it very descriptive.
So type that in.
Don't always type that fast.
And then, I'm going to
add an attribute in here.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to specify an
IT-based attribute,
and I'm going to specify the
IP range that corresponds
to the internal office.
Now, when I go ahead
and save that really,
really quickly, that is going
to show up in my list over here.
It says that my
level is created,
and down here I can see that new
policy is in my list of Access
Context Manager policies.
All right.
So far, so good.
So next, I'm going
to go in and I'm
going to configure the
Identity Aware Proxy.
So I'm going to go in, I'm
going to pick my project.
I'm going to click
on the service--
the back-end service that
connects to the HR app--
and then, I'm going to go in.
I'm going to add
members, which allows
me to say what group of
users that this policy is
going to apply to.
Remember, we're identity-aware.
That's the key point of this.
And so I'm going to add
in the group name, which
includes all the contractors.
I'm going to select the
policy that we just defined.
There it is.
Scroll down from
the Acme Office.
And I'm going to
save all of this.
It's going to instantiate.
It's going to get loaded
along with the other policies
that you see there on the right.
And so, that's the
admin experience.
It's really straightforward.
So this might have seemed--
wow, this is really complex.
But it's actually fairly
simple to step through.
All right.
Now let's flip it over and take
a look at the user experience.
So we're in a
browser, because it's
modern app for a
modern end-user.
And look, I'm on the
Wi-Fi inside of Acme Corp.
So we're going to hit
the URL for the HR app.
Our user is going to
be asked to sign in.
OK.
We do that.
We put in our password.
And now, because we
have that policy,
we're going to be asked to
authenticate with a security
key-- again, according
to our policy.
And since we're satisfied
all the requirements--
we're in the office,
we're authenticated,
we're authenticated
with the security key--
we can get in and get
access to that app.
So now let's change things
up a little bit further
and see what happens when we
don't meet the conditions.
So now we're working remotely.
You can see that we go
on, and we're actually
on Starbucks public Wi-Fi
out there on Third Street.
And so we're going to
go in and [AUDIO OUT]
for the HR app [AUDIO OUT].
Just like we did before.
Hopefully my mic does not
die while I go through this.
I only have to talk for
another minute or two here,
so we're hoping.
And we're asked to sign
in with the security key.
But what happens now?
The login fails because
we didn't meet all
the requirements in the policy.
So here-- look.
We have multiple layers.
We have the infrastructure.
We have the app.
We have the user.
We have protection that's
working at every level,
working in concert to
provide the security
and ease of use for the modern
end-user and the way they work.
And one last thing-- we didn't
talk too much about devices,
although that's one way
you can define policies.
And device trust is a
really, really key input
for this context-aware
access model.
We know that we can get device
context from Chrome browser
via an extension, but we know
many organizations already
have mobile management
solutions in place
that they're using to secure
this mobile workforce.
So today, we announced something
we called our BeyondCorp
Alliance.
What it is is a partnership with
a number of the key endpoint
and mobile security vendors who
can help provide device status
data back into Google
Cloud from their products.
So you can use the data that's
coming from these platforms
to make better access
decisions on whether or not
that product says the device
is in a safe state or not.
So it's great
validation, I think,
for our vision and
approach of what
we're doing here
from other leaders
in the end-user
computing security space.
And that's really a great
segue way into devices.
The final layer we want to
talk about is the device.
And there is a bunch here
we want to go through,
so I'm going to turn
that over to Eugene.
EUGENE LIDERMAN: Really
quickly diving in,
it's so hard to see everybody.
The light is shining so bright.
It's like nobody's
actually here.
So when it comes to
devices, taking a step back
about devices for a second.
Obviously, you know Google
has Chrome OS and Android OS,
and we work with a variety
of ecosystem partners, device
manufacturers.
Obviously, we have
our own devices,
but there's a huge,
broad ecosystem
of partners out there.
One of the things that's
really important when
it comes to both
Android OS and Chrome OS
is Google's commitment to
transparency and openness.
I think Rob touched on
that a little bit earlier.
Obviously, Android
is open-source.
Chrome OS is built on
Chromium, which is open-source.
Anybody can go see the
contributions that we
make, the changes that we make.
We blog about new
features as they come out.
We publish in-depth
white papers and reviews.
We actually just published an
Android security and privacy
journal review a
couple weeks back,
and we also publish transparency
reports to highlight
the state of the ecosystem.
So we have an Android
ecosystem transparency report.
We also have a Chrome safe
browsing transparency report.
It's just part of our ethos.
We try to be transparent
with everything
we do when it comes to these
mobile operating systems.
Speaking of security, I think
Rob touched on this before.
Obviously, you hear it a lot.
It's all about secure by design.
Security is a
foundational principle.
We have dedicated security teams
for both Chrome OS Android OS.
We're continually improving
security, always adding
additional hardware-based
security features,
anti-exploitation techniques,
and just implementing it
at every layer.
You probably heard that
he said defense in depth,
layered security, the
onion model-- whatever
analogy you want to use.
We're constantly
beefing up our security
for these operating systems.
Just to highlight
some of the stack.
Obviously, like I mentioned,
hardware-based security.
We obviously used
the Linux kernel.
So we implement
a lot of security
around sandboxing app
security, security
for the data on the devices.
One of the things that's
interesting about having
a broad ecosystem of
partners is, obviously,
coming up with design
principles and requirements
and then making sure that
these partners are actually
implementing.
Everything's done.
So on the Android side, we have
the compatibility definition
document that states what must
be implemented by our partners,
and then they go through
various conformance tests
like CTS, VTS, STS to make
sure that they conform
and these devices
ship to our standards.
Starting with
hardware-backed security,
I think Rob mentioned it a
little bit on the GCP side.
Of course, we want to make sure
that when the device boots up,
it boots into a verified state
so we have verified boot.
Verified boot, for anybody
that doesn't know it,
basically verifies the boot-up
process cryptographically
at every stage.
So if something bad happens
during the boot process,
it will alert the user
and react from there.
Some examples for verified
boot and why it's necessary.
Of course, obviously
malware is a universal risk.
The first thing
malware will try to do
is modify the system
partition and persist.
And so, with verified
boot, when the device
boots up, if something
bad happens it catches.
It notifies the user.
And since these operating
systems are modern,
they actually have
two copies of the OS.
So what it will do is,
if the primary copy is
in a known bad
state, it will try
to roll back to the other
copy if it's the same version.
In terms of additional
platform security features that
are hardware-based,
of course, both OSes
have full on-device
encryption that
actually is file-based
encryption, so
full data arrest.
They both leverage the
hardware-based security
for key generation
and key storage.
They both, of course, benefit
from using the Linux kernel.
And so they're both implemented
with mandatory access
control where everything
is broken down
in specific sub-components, kind
of protecting one from another,
making sure that if
something bad does happen it
doesn't go across the entire OS.
And then, of course,
as Rob touched earlier,
with sandboxing, the same thing
happens on the device OSes.
Of course, we
implement application
sandboxing for both OSes where
every single app is isolated.
It has its own resources
such as processing, memory,
and storage, and one cannot go
and eavesdrop on one another.
And the last thing is, you'll
see over the last couple years
both OSes have heavily added
additional anti-exploitation
techniques and methods--
so address space
layout randomization
in both the user space and
the kernel, data execution
prevention, control
flow integrity.
The whole mission there is that
the more these techniques we
can apply--
obviously, these are large OSes.
Hundreds of thousands,
millions of lines of code.
So if we can implement
additional methodologies
like this, we basically can
help prevent a potential bug
or vulnerability from becoming
exploitable and compromising
the entire operating system.
So the next big
thing, and I think
Rob touched a little
bit on how easy it
is to update on the cloud side.
On the mobile device side,
patching is also improved.
Obviously everybody
knows patch Tuesdays
and all those good examples.
On Chrome OS and Android OS,
we provide a nice cadence
for patches.
For Chrome OS, security patches
come out every three weeks.
Two to three weeks for Android.
We provide monthly security
bulletins to the ecosystem.
The real benefit
there is that we've
decoupled security updates
from feature updates,
so they're smaller,
easier to take.
The goal is to make
sure that users
have an easy way of
adopting these updates,
and so both OSes levered
seamless updates.
What that means is, since both
OSes have two copies of the OS
on the device, what happens
is, when the user is idle
on the device-- the device is
just idle and not being used--
the updates download
in the background.
And when it's ready to
install, it notifies the user.
So all the user has to do is hit
restart and all of the sudden
the device reboots and you're
now running the latest update.
Behind the scenes, what really
happens is as the OS reboots,
it now switches to
that secondary copy.
It verifies it.
And if something bad
happens, the nice thing
is it reverts back to
the last known good copy.
So there's no risk of
losing data or information.
On the Android side, obviously
since you walk around
with your device, it's not
always plugged into power
and you're using it,
we're a little bit more
gentle in the way
we do these updates.
So we obviously wait until
the device is plugged in.
You're on Wi-Fi, and
it's sitting there idle
so it doesn't impact
your usage of the device.
Of course, everybody
here is probably
familiar with the
Google Play Store.
Google Play Store is what
all Android devices, all GMS
devices, have for
access to apps.
That's our central
app repository.
There's obviously millions
of apps in the Play Store.
What a lot of people don't
know is that Chrome OS also
supports Android apps, and
it also has the Play Store.
And so, for an
enterprise deployment,
you can actually
deploy these apps
through what we call
Managed Google Play.
This is where you can allow IT
to provide a curated experience
for your applications,
so you can
decide what applications
you want to deploy.
They have that nice view of just
those approved applications.
You can push them automatically
down to the device.
You can control update policies.
You can actually manage
app configurations,
where if an app
developer supports
various configurations--
obviously, every
environment is different.
This allows them to
customize certain things
and make changes
as they see fit.
And what's really neat,
especially on the Android side,
is that since we do
support multiple management
models with fully managed
and BYOD with a work profile,
you can actually end up having a
personal instance of Play where
the user can download
whatever apps they choose.
And then in the work
profile-- which is basically
a separate Linux
user on the device
although it's in the
same user experience--
you end up having
a separate Managed
Google Play that IT can curate.
And there's that
perfect separation
so that IT's not overreaching
onto the personal side
for the user and their device.
Obviously, I think
I touched earlier,
malware is a universal risk.
Rob touched on
Chrome Safe browsing,
which is widely used across
Chrome OS and Android.
The other thing that we
have is Google Play Protect,
which is our built-in
anti-malware solution.
It's actually the largest,
or most widely used
anti-malware solution out there.
It basically scans
over 50 billion apps
across two billion
devices every single day.
On the back end, it also
analyzes and reanalyzes
about 500,000 apps
every single day.
It leverages machine learning,
artificial intelligence,
static analysis, dynamic
analysis, heuristics,
heat maps, and many
other techniques,
and it works for both off-play
and on-play as well as offline.
So even if the device
is not connected,
it's still scanning
and remediating.
And if it finds a potentially
harmful application, which
is what we on the Android
security and privacy side
refer analogous to malware,
it can remediate that
and remove it off the device or
notify the user, and so forth.
Like I had mentioned earlier,
we talked about transparency
and openness.
We publish an annual year
in review, which we just
published two weeks ago.
This year, the likelihood of--
you have a higher likelihood
of dying in a bathtub
than you do of installing a
potentially harmful application
from the Play Store.
I know, very morbid.
Nobody likes that
stat for some reason.
But I still went with it.
So this is something
new that we just added.
We just announced this today.
Again, Rob touched on
hardware security keys.
Of course, G Suite
supports this.
A lot of third-party solutions
as well support this.
As of today, you can actually
use your Android phone
as a security key.
It's basically Android
Nougat and above.
That's a billion-plus
devices that
have the ability to now
leverage this functionality.
On all of those
devices, it actually
does use hardware-based
security,
because it's using the Trusted
Execution Environment to store
those keys.
And then, specifically on Pixel
3 devices that have the Titan M
chip, it actually leverages
that discrete tamper-resistant
hardware with the strongbox API.
These, of course, work over
Bluetooth with your existing
laptops and desktops.
One of the key things
that we focus on
is measurable security.
We like to set benchmarks.
We like to see how we do.
And so, this is
actually something
that Gartner
publishes every year.
They have a new report
actually coming out very soon,
so this is the previous report.
But this is the mobile
OS comparison report.
It's pretty comprehensive.
There's about 28 categories, and
it focuses on platform security
features like network security,
OS updates, app updates,
and then specific
enterprise requirements
around policy management,
authentication controls,
key management, and so forth.
And what you'll see highlighted
there in the orange box,
the ones that scored the
highest in this report
were all Android devices--
Android Oreo, the Pixel
2 on Android Oreo,
and a Samsung device
on Android Oreo.
In fact, the Pixel 2
received a high rating
in 24 out of 28 categories,
and comparatively
if you look at some of the other
OSes, they scored half of that.
So to close, Google Cloud
with GCP, G Suite, Chrome,
and Android help you
securely enable--
this is the last slide that
I never could get right--
securely enable
modern, and these
are computing with
security capabilities
from the device to
the data center.
We can help keep your
enterprises secure
and your users productive.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]